senhoras e senhores
bom dia - matheus eu vim aqui falar com
vocês hoje um pouco sobre dinheiro e
também um pouco sobre felicidade e como
essas coisas se relacionam à final que o
dinheiro o dinheiro é uma convenção o
dinheiro é uma coisa que em algum
momento da nossa história como sociedade
nós combinamos que passaria a marcar o
valor de todas as coisas e até por um
motivo prático nós não mais trocaríamos
coisas por coisas e sim tudo por
dinheiro que significa a gente já
significou acabou com o escambo e
deixamos trocar por exemplo uma galinha
por um queijo minas uma garrafa de
cachaça
nesse momento a gente passou a trocar
essa mesma galinha o dinheiro em ainda
outro com essa quantidade de dinheiro
foi apurou pela galinha de volta pelo
queijo minas garrafa de cachaça ou mesmo
um pouquinho de cada um nisso acontece
uma coisa muito maluca que a gente possa
mensurar tudo em dinheiro todas as
coisas a gente passa a marcar com o
valor monetário
então hoje quando você trabalha o mês
inteiro e no final do mês você recebe
seu salário
basicamente você está trocando o seu
tempo a sua força de trabalho
seu valor por uma quantia em dinheiro
que aquela quantia ela significa quanto
você vale pelo seu empregador jogos do
valor e você então como indivíduo você
passa a utilizar esse dia para viver pra
consumir para viver para comprar coisas
e buscar sua felicidade
chegou então a felicidade e o que é a
felicidade
a felicidade é uma coisa bem mais
objetiva para cada um
a felicidade é ter um significado
diferente para algumas pessoas a
felicidade significa família significa
você ter pessoas queridas de quem você
cuida e você tenha talvez o dinheiro
suficiente para garantir o mínimo dessa
necessidade das pessoas atendidas por
outras pessoas a felicidade pode ter
mais ligada ao consumo
você tem um carro esporte o carro da
moda pode fazer viagens caras e mais do
que isso poderá tirar muito voto disso
com seu iphone de última geração e
compartilhar nas redes e porque a gente
fizer uma maneira de fazer isso porque
muitas vezes a sociedade liga então o
dinheiro ao sucesso e um sucesso e
felicidade
então a gente aquela imagem
quem é o caso de sucesso é o cara que tá
com o dinheiro que esbanjam estou
tentando e o inverso também é verdadeiro
a gente passa a ligar a falta de
dinheiro o fracasso e acaba que você
mente mente a gente julga as pessoas o
tempo todo quando disso
e será que a felicidade ela realmente
está nisso eu vou demonstrar processo é
um exemplo que não pra melhorar por
exemplo a felicidade isso aqui
para felicidade dos sapatos é que
realmente tem hotel e ela trabalha
drogas o trabalho por dinheiro e com
isso temos a parceria garante ser
plenamente feliz mas porque eu tô
falando sobre isso hoje porque
recentemente na minha história aconteceu
uma coisa que me fez pensar um pouco
mais sobre esse tema que eu queria
dividir com vocês eu sou sócia uma
startup chama smart bote e nós
trabalhamos com robôs investimento na
bolsa de valores é uma coisa super
ligada tem dinheiro aplicado tecnologia
e hoje em dia está muito legal falar
disso mas fala pra você está no negócio
difícil e no brasil é mais difícil ainda
a nossa empresa de 2011 e desde então eu
os meus ossos têm mais três sócios
trabalhamos com muito afinco pretendo
fazer negócio irá isso significa que
durante mais de cinco anos o que nós
dormimos pensando sobre acordamos
pensando sobre pensamos e falamos o dia
inteiro sobre é a smart bote e mais do
que isso
durante muito tempo maior parte desse
tempo a gente fazer isso pela motivação
pelo propósito paixão porque a empresa
simplesmente não ganhava dinheiro
suficiente para pagar um bom salário
então há felizmente esse jogo virou
recentemente começamos a crescer
bastante acelerar a tanto com o
faturamento legal e no ritmo de
crescimento acelerado e nesse momento
apareceu um fundo de investimento esses
fundos que procure empresas startup de
tecnologia para investir com a proposta
de comprar a nossa empresa toda uma
parte ea gente isso nos provocou a
pensar como o valor do smart bote porque
bati bote pra gente é mais do que uma
profissão é muito talvez nosso projeto
de vida nossa vida profissional do mpu
mais seis anos aí nós somos
relativamente jovens é desde que se
entende como gente lá que a gente coloca
nossa energia mas se chegou proposta
para outro botar um caminhão de dinheiro
aí eu pensei cara eu sou feliz hoje
trabalhando smart bote mas será que eu
posso eu vou trocar isso nunca meu
dinheiro
será que então a eu seria mais feliz
eu acho que o ser humano está sempre
buscando a felicidade eu cheguei
será que o dinheiro realmente uma
felicidade tem um preço pra isso
ou será que ele estava certo a
felicidade não se compra
bom o final dessa história que não vemos
e deu acho que foi a decisão acertada
porque nós passamos a crescer ainda mais
e foi até bom para mim marcar um pouco
de preço e colocar mais lentos nosso
negócio mas eu fiquei com a pulga atrás
da orelha porque é uma coisa que eu
nunca nunca tinha parado para pensar
porque a resposta é essa relação em
dinheiro felicidade porque quando
pensava antigamente era quase intuitivo
pensar que era uma relação linear quanto
mais dinheiro se tem mais realizado mais
feliz você vai ser só coisa começa
começa a refletir e até mesmo observar
outras pessoas em outros exemplos também
que nem sempre isso é verdade e até que
um dia estava vendo um podcast que eu
gosto muito que mandar rodou e eles
fizeram o sódio apresentou o estudo na
economia americana que traz exatamente
qual é o formato dessa curva uma base
muito mais científica acadêmica que é
basicamente isso
esse estudo ele mostrava que sim
o dinheiro ele pode te ajudar a ser mais
feliz até um certo ponto chega um
determinado ponto que você vai ganhar
mais dinheiro mas o incremento na sua
felicidade não vai ser tão maior e
também mostrava que o dinheiro não
garante a felicidade
ele vai te ajudar de certa maneira mas
se você já é infeliz com 1 1 milhão
vai ser mais um milhão que vai deixar
feliz mas eu comecei eu começo a pensar
então qual é o valor dessa felicidade
enquanto de renda que eu tenho que ter
por mês para conseguir ser plenamente
feliz que eu vou chamar de um do ponto
ótimo da ajuda o dinheiro em relação à
felicidade convertendo dólar para real
esses puro chegava o valor era mais ou
menos de 11 mil reais por mês de renda
pra garantir esse ponto ótimo de
felicidade
é claro que isso vai variar muito com
essa variedade de acordo com a cidade
consertar
então possivelmente nos mora em belo
horizonte falou pode ser menor do que em
são paulo que sua vez pode ser melhor
que em nova iorque e vai variar muito de
acordo com a sociedade as pessoas com
quem você convive porque nós nos
comparamos com as pessoas o tempo todo
mas eu boto peguei esse número de base e
comecei a pensar então como eu garanto
esse ponto ótimo financeiro para poder
me preocupar com outras coisas está
feliz
em outras coisas e também comecei a
pensar que poxa estou envelhecendo estou
com 30 anos hoje
mas aí na nossa vida a gente nasce
cresce e começa a trabalhar durante o
tempo a gente está produzindo a gente
consegue pegar e fazer dinheiro e até
mesmo de um mandar dinheiro no futuro
porque que mandaria o futuro e investir
você tá pegando o dinheiro que deixa de
gastar ele
você basicamente está adotando uma linha
do tempo fala se cada um vamos ver se no
futuro uma certa velocidade porque um
determinado momento da sua vida você
pode não conseguir mais trabalhar ou não
queria mais trabalhar
e você vai ter que conseguir consumir
essas reservas que tem aqui e em tudo
que aconteceu no brasil hoje a gente não
tem mais certeza qualquer ajuda do
governo noé mesmo no futuro então essa
missão tem que ser de cada um de vocês
então comecei a pensar a cara como eu
garanto aquele ponto ótimo de 12 mil
reais de renda o mês pra ter dinheiro
suficiente para alavancar a minha
felicidade no futuro
eu gosto de números então debrucei
comecei a fazer um monte conta planilha
mas planilha e queria dividir um pouco
do que eu acho que estamos com vocês e
pra fazer isso de uma forma mais fácil
pra não ficar falando de juros sobre
juros matemática financeira eu peguei
emprestado aquela fórmula da segunda lei
de newton que a força de uma marca dessa
aceleração que apesar de muito novo e
nem lembrar mas que significam a suíça
que se inspirou na escola tem certeza
que vocês lembram
então ao invés da nossa força vai ser a
nossa felicidade àqueles 11 mil reais de
renda a massa é o montante de dinheiro
que a gente consegue guardar pra mandar
pro futuro e aceleração basicamente a
taxa de juros com que velocidade e
tamanho esse dinheiro pra fazer ele
significa mais vale mais no futuro
começando falando da poupança um
investimento mais clássico
historicamente no brasileiro você e vou
trabalhar com a caderneta de poupança e
se você colocar mil reais por mês na
poupança enquanto você atingir esse
ponto ótimo 36 anos
digamos que você consiga colocar um
pouquinho mais dois mil reais por mês
então o nosso prazo pai cai para 26 anos
e se você consegue colocar um pouquinho
mais três mil reais por mês de
investimento enviado do futuro
você chega nesse ponto em 21 anos esse
resultado é interessante você consegue
realmente baixar e atinge a garantia da
tranquilidade do ponto ótimo antes mas
eu penso
tenho esse dinheiro já que consiga
investir 3 mil reais por mês para
decidir o futuro e mais do que isso será
que estou disposto a fazer isso a fazer
essa troca de uma coisa que possa
consumir posso gastar que eu posso ver
agora e de ter levado três mil reais por
mês para garantir uma possível
felicidade no futuro
então vai analisar sob outra ótica isso
mudará aceleração segundo o tipo de
investimento colocando o dinheiro na
poupança como um recomeço 36 anos
se for pra toda renda fixa um ser e de
um tesouro direto aquele investimento
com o gerente do seu banco pode
recomendar a gente cai pra 28 anos já
posso descontar o imposto de renda
só que a boa notícia é que têm outra
alternativa que pode ser bem mais
interessante ter uma alternativa
consegue diminuir até a metade o ponto o
tempo vamos atingir esse ponto ótimo de
felicidade não só dotar de mais um tipo
de robô de investimento que consegue um
rendimento muito maior com risco
relativamente baixo e com a mágica de
contar pra vocês estão com a mágica
a mágica ver esse cara aqui o nome desse
karl markovics ele é um economista
americano e ele criou uma teoria de uma
teoria modelo do portfólio moderna tem o
grupo moderno portfólio e até ganhou o
nobel de economia em 1990 com isso é
basicamente uma teoria que ela fala o
seguinte se você tem um caminhão de
dinheiro desse lado independente como é
pequeno ou grande
você tem um universo de ativos para você
pode investir em títulos de renda fixa e
renda variável tesouro poupança cdb
ações como você faz para dividir o seu
dinheiro nesse monte de coisas que você
tem para investir de modo a maximizar
sua rentabilidade e minimizar seu risco
ao mesmo tempo a teoria muito
interessante e só que o problema é que é
muito difícil de ser colocado em prática
porque é muito cara
exige muita informação exige muitas
contas em capital intelectual
extremamente capacitado
então basicamente quem conseguir fazer
investimento nisso essa teoria antiga o
nobel foi 90 então até pouco tempo atrás
que conseguiu botar em prática era quem
tinha muito dinheiro conseguia contratar
a equipe especialistas pra fazer isso
funciona para essa pessoa
ou seja o caso já tinha passado aquele
ponto onde uma infelicidade mas dinheiro
não faz mais feliz mais diferença
felicidade das pessoas mas só estava
disponível pra ele
só que aí que entra a revolução na
tecnologia startup
de uns anos pra cá algumas status são
democratizando o acesso a isso a esse
tipo de coisa pegando todo esse capital
intelectual todo esse capital a
especializado e botando dentro do box e
nelas baixo radicalmente o custo de
implementação desse tipo dessa teoria na
prática e permitem que você comece a
seguir esse tipo é esse tipo de locação
de financeira e começando com não com
alguns milhões mas com alguns milhares
de dólares de reais pelos estados
americanos puxaram isso fora do brasil
um cão barry mcgaw from essa estátua
onde elas são 13 achamos de unicórnios
seu status que falava em alguns bilhões
de dólares e mais recentemente no brasil
por status é como magnética velhos e o
whoi que já permitem isso para pessoa
física comum como a partir de 5 10 mil
reais consegue ter essa taxa de retorno
do seu investimento e se eu pudesse
passar pra você só essa a mensagem que
se você com pouco esforço através dessa
etapa de uma tecla da tecnologia
você pode atingir o ponto ótimo de
felicidade e metade do tempo já estaria
satisfeito
só que como eu disse a gente falou até
agora de como otimizar essa forma de
mandar o dinheiro pra frente mas até o
outro lado o lado a felicidade nesse
processo todo e como otimizar sua
felicidade porque com a limpeza da
cidade
tem uma frase um trecho muito legal do
filósofo douglas adams que escreveu o
guia do mochileiro das galáxias que ele
fala um pouco sobre a terra eo planeta
que a terra tinha um problema que a
maioria dos habitantes estavam sendo
felizes e toda vez que alguém propõe uma
solução para esse problema
essa solução estava sempre ligada à
movimentação de pequenos pedaços de
papel colorido com alguns meios escritos
neles
só que isso é muito curioso porque não
era esperado papel colorido que sentirem
felizes com a felicidade ela transporta
ela vai transpor isso a gente falou que
vão otimizar mandar o dinheiro no futuro
para garantir um mínimo dessa felicidade
mas como otimizar a felicidade
então sem sair do tema dinheiro tem umas
dicas pra vocês
a primeira ligada com você gasta seu
dinheiro que ele mostra a comparação das
ruas do nível de felicidade uma pesquisa
quando você gasta dinheiro com uma
experiência e não com consumo do
material ea quitavam comportar comprovar
o que você gasta o mesmo montante de
dinheiro contratando uma experiência que
com a experiência mundial
em show o mesmo cinema ver um futebol o
site falava de paraquedas uma corrida de
kart
essa felicidade ela além de ser maior
imediatamente após o incidente do
dinheiro ela se segura ela dura com mais
tempo você fala que é insustentável
também né
outra pesquisa bem interessante essa
daqui
ela mostra uma correlação no mundo e
onde todos os países que estão em verde
aqui são países onde houve o verbo de
pessoas um grupo de pessoas que se
mostrou mais feliz que a outra que outro
grupo e qualquer diferença o grupo mais
feliz é o grupo que doou dinheiro e faz
doações recorrentes ou seja gastar
dinheiro sem ver um com o outro querendo
bem sem esperar nada em troca
já pode fazer feliz está cientificamente
comprovado mas pra finalizar
eu acho que é importante pensar nesse
tema que a felicidade não estava ligada
a cada um
a gente conversou no começo que para
alguns pode uma família para uns pode
ser um bem que nem sempre está ligado
dinheiro às vezes tem coisas simples
você pode fazer na sua vida não deixa
mais feliz da minha vida alguma mudança
que eu fiz que foi bem drástica e
radical que aumentou muito o meu livro
de falar em felicidade posso dizer que
estou em outro patamar
não foi ligada compra nem de material de
uma experiência como essa aqui de baixo
2 gálatas que adotei e vou dizer que com
certeza me tornar uma pessoa mas eles
causa disso mas além do dinheiro para
comprar essas pestes
obrigado
[Aplausos]